irán reaccionó hoy a la noticia
publicada por el diario estadounidense
the new york times en el que aseguraba
que días atrás el presidente de donald
trump se había reunido con sus
principales asesores para discutir la
posibilidad de atacar dentro de irán al
programa nuclear iraní en las próximas
semanas el portavoz del gobierno iraní
ali ravi dijo hoy que irán respondería
decisivamente si era atacado por eeuu y
si bien aquellos asesores
norteamericanos según el diario the new
york times' lograron disuadir al
presidente
trump de un ataque dentro de irán
todavía hay algunas cartas que se
barajan por ejemplo un ataque
cibernético o ataques a otros países o
organizaciones aliadas a irán por
ejemplo las milicias en irak y es que en
irán y en otros países de la región hay
bastante sospecha sobre los movimientos
que ha hecho el presidente de donald
trump en los últimos días especialmente
en el pentágono y se sospecha que alguna
acción importante podría realizar antes
de dejar la casa blanca los próximos 2
meses días atrás el secretario de la
organización hezbollah en el líbano
había llamado a todo el movimiento de la
resistencia como se llaman los aliados
de irán para que estuvieran alerta a
cualquier ataque